okay we're really quick addendum from
the previous story we discovered my
friend Gordon who was a freshman at
UConn just said I wasn't able to get
into the Shapiro event either everyone
wanted to go more conservatives on
campus than people think
thank you Gordo by the way the Justice
Department is asking to see a memo
reportedly outlining serious wrongdoing
at the FBI and Justice Department under
President Obama house Intel chairman
Devin Nunez is taking steps to
declassify the memo summarizing the
findings of his Russia investigation
well a letter from the Justice
Department charges that it would be
extraordinary reckless tonight to
release the memo without first giving
the DOJ and FBI the opportunity to
review it let's sort this all out with
someone who's read the memo Congressman
Peter King of New York I thought you're
gonna be here tonight with me
congressman who serves on the Intel
committee great to see you how you doing
I'm doing great Laura how are you I'm
great so what is the lords of Justice
Department the FBI they're suddenly all
squirrelly about the release of this
memo what goes on your whisper it's a
four page memo put together by a very
talented professional staff on the
committee reviewed by all the Republican
members made available to all the
members of the committee and voted out
of the committee last week to be made
available to all the members of the
house their findings in here are very
very significant showing I believe in
the terrible mistakes or deliberate
wrongdoing at high levels and right now
the Justice Department and whatever
Newlands plans on doing because over 200
members of the House and looked at it
only about 10 Democrats by the way and
there is a a climber by the public to
see the memo we're gonna make sure
there's nothing in there any small light
in there may reveal the source or method
and that is pretty much finished that'll
be done and then we're gonna vote this
week on releasing it at that stage if we
get a majority vote which we will it
will go to the president the United
States he will decide if it can be made
public or not if he does it will be made
known to the public this letter from the
Justice Department Laura listen I have
great respect for the FBI I generally
have great respect for the Justice
Department but we have gotten almost no
cooperation from them at all over the
last several months we had to go to
court she had documents we were entitled
to long hard fights they had basic
documents which we have an absolute
to see and now Justice Department if we
gave them this memo what they would do
is and we passed out to all the friends
in the media to tear it down before it
even gets out there everything that's in
that memo is from the Justice Department
information we found there's no
surprises there to them they just want
to be ready I think to attack it and
they want to attack it yeah make a
pre-emptive attack on it we're not gonna
let them I understand I've not spoken to
Devon but I've spoken to his staff
people tonight and he fully intends to
go ahead we're not going to show it to
the Justice Department
congressman knowing what you know now
you've read the read the memo you've
seen the evidence so far do you have
faith as of now in the upcoming result
of this investigation knowing what you
know now and what you've seen well I've
sat through I don't know whether it's
hundreds of hours I mean I've been in
there for probably 20 witnesses have
come before our committee and certainly
all the major ones have sat there for
seven eight nine hours again all the big
names you've heard about I've been there
for that I have not heard one word yet
indicating any collusion now I don't
know with Bob Mull has anything else but
he's talking to many of the same people
so if they come out with any finding of
collusion at all based on what I've
heard then I would say that they're not
doing the job but on the other hand I
think right now I believe the
president's lawyers feel this is going
in the right direction with all the
improprieties that went on here the fact
that this investigation I believe should
never ever been started in the first
place I look upon it either
intentionally or unintentionally as a
political hit job
I mean we're losing facts inside of the
fact here that you have the leading law
enforcement organization in the world
investigating a presidential candidate
based on the flimsiest of evidence I
wouldn't even call it evidence on the
flimsiest rumors that's what this was
based on and that's a terrible precedent
to set you can do that to any candidate
if you wanted to and when you bring the
FBI into a political campaign it's wrong
well I want to play for you a clip I
watched this afternoon of a former RNC
chief Michael Steele he was on MSNBC and
he was criticizing Congress and anyone
in the media who would cast aspersions
on the FBI here let's watch we have now
has set up a wholesale operation between
the White House and Capitol Hill
to sully the reputation of good men and
women who work inside the FBI because of
as you noted how our so some emails yes
they're problematic but let the
appropriate authorities ferret that out
to do what they're doing the the end
game they're playing right now what they
don't seem to understand it could blow
up in their face just as much as it
could sell you the FBI response
congressman we are talking about a
handful of people at the top the FBI is
now staying outstanding organization
there are people at the top that will
have not served the FBI well and I would
say the rank and file of the FBI
appreciates what we're doing because
they are concerned I mean I've heard
from retired FBI people who are shocked
about what's coming out and to me the
emails and text messages that's all
important that's really just an
indication of this investigation from
the start should never have been started
it's based on a false premise and that's
continued right through and whether
we're talking about the FBI whether
we're talking about John Brennan of the
CIA and others this to me has all been a
concerted effort to go after Donald
Trump with and yet a lot of reason you
can disagree with Donald Trump but to
say that he was colluding with the enemy
when there's no evidence there to me is
shameful and that's going on now I think
it's significant that now it's being
leaked to the New York Times talking
about obstruction of justice about
events that happened six months after
the campaign was over the campaign where
the Russians apparently colluded yeah we
noticed the leaking right as things
started turning really good for Trump on
the economy and the shutdown then all
the leaks came from the Muller team
congressman King thank you so much great